has watched only basic anime but says
they are a weeb there's only one answer
right 3 2 1 I feel
green we all disagree yes Joey is like
anime mentioned red
flag what's up Gamers and Tik Tok
friends welcome back to another episode
of trash taste I'm your host Tik Tok
friends I'm your host us should do good
intro yeah I not even alliteration Joey
Tik Tok friends give me a letter and
I'll do an alliteration right now the B
what's up you bootylicious
[__] welcome back to another episod
of trash podcast I'm Joey and I'm with
Connor and Gant as always and uh we're
going to be doing something a little bit
different we're going to be following a
Tik Tok Trend oh that's where you kind
of came up with that's why I said the
Tik Tok friends if you guys have been on
Tik Tok or I guess YouTube shorts uh any
short form content then you might have
known about these little things called
red flags versus green flags uh today
we're going to get a bunch of potential
red flags or are we including beige
Flags in this what's a beige flag expl
this is totally new in my understanding
a beige flag so if a red flag is a very
bad trait that someone has green trait
is a good trait that someone has a beige
flag is more of an oddity or a quirk
like let's say like boring or well let's
say if Gant wakes up every morning and
just stares at the window for 10 minutes
I think that that' be a beige flag I'm
like that's a red flag for me or or or
you mean waking up and just shouting at
yourself in the mirror that would be a
beige flag like if you if you lived with
me and you heard that every that would
be either a beige to Red Flag right
right cuz that is just a weird thing so
beig is kind of in the middle between we
all we all have weird things that we do
sure and so it's one of those don't
think of it is like in the middle it's
not good or bad think of it beige being
reserved for like a quirky like an odity
yeah because it can also be no flag it
doesn't have to be a green or red flag
quot surely a beige flag is just a no
flag then no no it's reserved
exclusively for weird quirks not it is
not indicative of a normal behavior why
did they decide to pick why did they
decide to pick the most boring color for
something because it's meant to be like
a flag is obviously when something goes
wrong right so it's a flag it's like oh
it's weird it's like there's something
weird here whereas if it's we just don't
if it's like hey he he replies to your
messages that's just not a flag because
that's normal behavior but a green flag
is going like the behavior is good and
but we can we can see how it goes okay
okay so basically we're going to be uh
we have we have a bunch of we could say
normal beige green or red okay sure so
no flag beige green or red we have a
bunch of topics in here that can be one
of the potential Flags potential Flags
cuz as you can tell we are three dating
experts out there probably most
experienced man of all time come on guys
come on we we we we decided to make our
own Alpha podcast
actually flag Al flag
it's finally some representation like it
helps to contextualize is how we view
something sure so so so how are we going
to do this we're going to read out let's
pull one out each one of yeah we're
going to pull out a topic out of
trashbox co uh out was a red
flag I'll keep my hand
in and then we'll we'll pull out a topic
we'll read it out we will individually
say whether it's a red flag or green
flag and then after discussion I guess
we can collectively what trash taste
deems a certain color should we do it
like that no I okay I got a better idea
uh can we get the whiteboards out oh my
God what are we doing cuz I feel like
it's better if we uh reveal what we
think at the same time I we're kind of
doing a little after dark inspired yeah
we're doing a little after dark inspired
a little after okay okay this is filmed
later in the day see cuz like I feel
everybody has their like red flags and
green flags with their partners and and
by the way we're specifically talking
about like Partners cuz obviously there
are like different flags for like
friends or like parents or like bosses
or whatever parents yeah
you know [__] [__] open they get
the belt out oh beige flag beige that's
that's a bit be uh so you Audio Only
listeners are not going to be able to
see what we do say what we're writing
down yes but we will say what we're
writing this is still from the last
after dark slightly agree slightly agree
all right let's uh okay so feel free to
play along at home uh let us know down
in the comments below what you think
about uh all of these what do you call
them like traits traits qu traits traits
however you want to call thema the
traits traits you know if you were to
play an RPG and they had these you would
see them as good or bad okay sure sure
so let's your character frequently get
drunk that's a bad trait to having a
character that you want see this is
going to be interesting cuz I don't
think I've ever actually like sat down
and about whether something is green or
red flag you know yeah and and there's a
lot of things that you know I think when
you're if you ever if you're fortunate
enough to ever get in a relationship you
learn
that did you say cuz God knows our
audience will never listen listen hey
come on all right I'm right here fans
having girlfriends and boyfriends fck
going to represents the every man here
he's the every man listen that's a red
flag list you know it's easy to be like
I would never date someone who has this
the you know a lot of the time life is a
lot different than that you don't
sometimes you date someone you find out
afterwards that they they like to
think the world is flat and and then you
know that's a kind of conversation you
got to figure out afterwards and I feel
as well like Flags change all the time
depending on what stage of your life you
are like some things you can be way more
tolerable about other things you just
like what is look how bouncy this thing
is oh my Lord the
[__] you're like a little kid now what
the hell what the heck it's so bouncy
ladies is that a red flag or a green
flag that's a that's a beige flag out of
the damn all right all right all right
all right let's see all right here we go
our first one is are we writing it down
then then yeah we I'm going to read it
out and then we write it down and reveal
okay here we go here's our first flag
our first flag is has the food pallet of
a
12-year-old isn't that just all of
us
okay do not put words in my mouth sir
okay okay okay holy [__] what what does
food of 12-year-old me see that's open
for
interpretation you can you can interpret
that how where you want how do I spell
beige is that well thanks for telling us
well I just realized b e i
g I wish I got that one in the spelling
get that one right
illiterate okay we get it okay we get it
all right we get it yours is beige all
right ready let's reveal in 3 2 1 it's a
red flag red flag why is it a red flag
okay I mean okay I'm I'm surprised not
all of us wrote down actually I'm not
surprised chice com
from okay first of all beige it's not
it's not a quirk to not [__] eat
anything everyone has a [__] Quirk
about something that's weird with their
taste buds that is that is that is not a
weird thing you interpreted that in the
I get we're on trash taste you
interpreted that sentences you have the
power is AKA you have one thing you
dislike I don't think that's how I
interpret what is your definition of uh
taste what was it I I interpreted that
as they have the palette of a
12-year-old palet of a 12-year-old they
won't eat most things you go to
restaurant they're not willing to try
stuff you know that's like a big part of
for me is that I like being able to sit
down and share meals with people and if
they're not willing to at least try
certain things hey I get it if you don't
you straight up don't like oie you know
you don't like oi and it comes out okay
that's fine we get that it is this is
linked to one of my biggest pet peeves
not just with Partners just with people
in general people who don't like put all
of this judgment on something that they
have little to know information or
knowledge about and don't even bother
trying okay but okay I guess I guess
there's like a way to interpret it but
how picky are we like saying right now
how picky are we talking about well
picture your average 12-year-old uh at a
restaurant or something right they're
going to probably pick the most like
when I was 12year old I wasn't [__]
exploring food or anything they probably
always eat the same thing they tend to
be like you know ordering with them is
is never fun like I think a fun part of
ordering when we all go out we're like
What are you just feeling and we just
kind of try a bunch of things yeah it's
like oh I've never tried that thing
before I'll give it a go people they're
like I will only eat this one thing
you're like oh okay I mean that's F or
they're like super specific about what
they can eat because they're comfortable
with it and that's fine like as as it
makes it sound like we hate these people
I don't there's no like nothing wrong
with it but it's like for me if I was to
be with someone that's something that I
would care about is being able to share
those food as someone who uh you know
famously [__] with everything in terms
of food you do [__] with too much though
I love that there are some you shouldn't
[__] with Joey no but like you know for
me it's like if you tell me that if I go
to a new country or something and you
and I see this like particular Cuisine
that I've never heard of don't even know
what the hell it is right cuz it's might
be in a completely different language I
don't know right never seen anything
like it before if the locals tell me
that it's good [__] it's edible you know
it might differ you know some people
like it some people don't that just
piques my curiosity of being like well I
want to try this thing out I want to
explore you show you're willing to try
something yeah I'm always willing to try
something out before I judge something
you know okay yeah I I agree with that
then I I would not be with someone if
they weren't willing to like try other
things yeah what if what if Sydney only
ate chicken nugs which is a cuz she's
from Wisconsin which is a possible time
cheese curs what if she only ate chees
she only ate like cheese curs and Fries
I've not met a single person that is as
bad as what you guys are talking about
though you never met I've met so many
people I have I have not I have like
even even I'm going to like you know
deep into like Wisconsin people are
willing to try out new things you know
they they might not always like it but
people are normally willing to at least
try something to be like nah just give
me a burger and cheese and cheese I've
met people who only eat like fast food
like they will not out of Preference
they just don't like anything else and
they're not I
understand most of the people I'm not
I'm not trying to be like because we
hate Americans so much I'm not trying to
be a dick but it most of the time people
I meet who are super picky are normally
American however I have met a bunch of
British people who also are [__] in
this I've met some Australians who are
like this you know the way they're just
like they're just not willing to try
anything prence preference to preference
this I'm also around Americans the most
I I'm around more Americans than not so
I feel like this is also why my judgment
is B skewed yeah but like you know I get
if like allergies are involved right
like obviously you can't you have
disease or you can't eat certain food
something that is physically stopping
you from eating or if there's something
physically stopping you like at a
chemical level of you not being able to
eat a certain thing yeah you know then I
then I understand your immune system
just hates you it's just an immune diff
then I get it but like if you look at
this thing and and you're just like the
one thing I okay this is one thing that
this pet peeve I hate the most is when
something comes out and before they've
even tried it they go what is
that and then they try and know every
single little detail and then after
hearing all the details they're like no
I'm not going to try okay but sometimes
sometimes there are things that you you
know you don't really have any interest
in wanting to [__] with like would you
would you feel that way of someone's
like now I'm good never trying Nat uh no
I think I think you should give anything
a go and if you don't like it then now
you know it's like you try it once you
don't like it okay that's completely
fine that you don't like I'm not going
to hate everyone who doesn't like Nat
obviously but like I'm going to hate you
even more if you say you don't like Nat
without even trying it out because as
we've found out you used to not like Nat
and then you tried it on after dark and
you [__] with there is some kind of
like psychological thing there where you
do you like almost fearing this food so
much that there's no possible part of
your brain will it tastes
orex I think yeah I me if I go
restaurant and like 50% plus of the
things you don't want to eat or you're
not willing to try I'm like okay well
then what like you know cuz for me
that's a lot that's like how I that's a
lot of my downtime is being able to
share those time totally yeah um we're
very fortunate we get to we get to go
out yeah I mean I I I say this because
okay so as long as they're willing to
try things that's why I didn't I didn't
put like I didn't put like red flag
because you put nothing no flag I I
guess guess you could just put no flag
okay no no flag you made it be like oh
that's a weird thing like like okay the
way I interpreted that is like taste bus
of a 12-year-old right that means they
just haven't gone out of their comfort
zone for like a lot of things cuz I
remember when I first started dating
Sydney she had not really had anything
but like American foods and she could
not handle spicy food like at all right
yeah so you know you could argue that
she had not had a lot of different
cultures food and now like she eats
spicier food than my mom because she
started da okay but spicy food I think
is a bit different cuz that's not a
taste that's a
sensation maybe to a Japanese person Jo
Joy Joey Joey Joey I think that is very
different I think in terms of the
palette of a 12-year-old is like we are
really going into the
definition no no no I'm not I'm not
going to let I'm not going to let this
one go yes okay Joey scientifically
whatever spiciness isn't a taste all
right Joey but you know if if you can't
have spicy food um like even to like
just a little bit of a spicy food me as
a tie I'm going to think that you're a
little baby that can't eat anything with
a little bit of spice he look I'm
someone who got out of that comfort zone
I used to not be able to eat any spice
growing up is a gradual thing it is it
grad and now I would say I'm pretty all
right you know Coco level I can go up to
a level four now no because that because
like here's here's the thing like I
think we like met someone about like
that thought this earlier but it's not
just the spice but it's like how
sensitive is your palette as well right
so some people can't handle Southeast
Asian food for example because it has
like a very very strong taste love it
and and you know I love it I love it
right but some Japanese people that I've
met and you know some some westers that
I've met as well that taste is just like
this this going to sound so weird
there's just too much seasoning there is
just too much seasoning and like to me
I'm and to me I'm like okay that's the
pet of a 12-year-old to me as a
Southeast Asian are you referring to one
of our staff going to for the first time
the other
day maybe but he is not the first person
I've met that has said that but context
one of our Japanese staff here at uh
trash taste went to a nandos the other
day in the UK and his review of nandos
was there's too much
flavor that's [__] up is [__] [__]
up that's [__] up to say so that's a
skill issue let's go let's do the next
one pull the next one next one stand too
long on the [__] 12-year-old top it
doesn't matter we can do this for as
long as we want to uh is it a red or
green flag when they don't use social
media H
[Music]
okay okay I'm going to I'm going to need
context I'm going like I'm thinking
about these and I'm like I need I need
some I need some
context okay what [__] that is the
context that is the context they don't
use social media okay is there Twitter
No Instagram no Facebook nothing nothing
what you can call social media they do
not use the only thing that I think I
will like I I I when I think of social
media I don't count stuff like uh
messaging or like line whereas it
strictly peer-to-peer communication
people they can text you but but you
can't find them on a webite I know that
is I know that is technically the
definition of like social media or like
social inter is talk P but I consider
that as a completely different app yeah
but if you include that then like snail
mail is so yeah right like I think no
one no one their right mind even though
the definition includes all of these
like would compare like texting to being
on Twitter it's not specifically talking
about social media websit okay ready 3
two one beig oh green I I decided put
green I was like listen I I'm terminally
online I I don't want someone who's also
terminally online okay so for me this is
I I thought about green at first because
obviously we're in a position where like
social being on social media is part of
our jobs right like we kind of have to
be on social media as public figures on
the internet but I think I thought at
first might have been green because
there might have been like a nice like
if your partner doesn't use social media
then that's a good excuse to like kind
of lay low on the social media and kind
of cool off on being terminally online
all the time but at the same time a lot
of like my cultural references that I
know a lot of like memes and stuff like
that also comes from social media I love
I love would I be able to like have a
fun existed before social media yes but
admittedly a lot of that human now is
rooted in social media I don't know I
think I don't you that's like saying hey
I can't get on with my parents cuz if I
say Among Us they're not going to
understand what I'm talking
about and I would argue actually that's
a good thing yeah that's a good thing
it's a good I want my parents to know I
pull the weight of three people's social
media usage I don't need another person
doing it even think you do like there
are there are more people nowadays that
are more terminally online than there
are that are not I think it's just like
how you spend it online like I streaming
all the time it's just different hours
like I don't I don't actually have that
much time to scroll all the time but I'm
just always online in some capacity so I
feel like I I would like to get away
from that when possible I think I think
I put down beige because in the sense of
like I don't yeah it is weird in this
day and age not have it it is very quk
they had to made the choice to do it a
little try Hardy if you ask me right
well depends how they're framing it like
if someone's like I'm not on social
media and it's like okay but do you know
anyone around you who's not on social
media I know some people yeah yeah how
how how do they like look at social
media uh they just they just kind of
okay they just kind of look at it as a
negative and they just want to live in
the moment I guess that's what they said
they they they want to be more focused
on the things that's immediately
surround them as opposed to what
everyone else is doing unfortunately
makes it harder get in contact with them
sometimes that's like I guess the
biggest downside but the reason I put
green flag is because I was thinking
about it and I was like if someone told
me they didn't use social media can I
think of any negative effects yeah I
think there's no downsides being on it
yeah I don't really see any downside to
someone not being on social media Al
there a lot of self-confidence generally
because you're not on it you're like I
feel confident in who I am I don't need
to be in this game of of clout see
because like that is definitely a good
thing as well but at the same time it's
like you know I think the benefit of you
know a partner and you being on social
media is that you can like say for
example like you know something that
everybody does nowadays which is just
like sharing memes or just like bringing
up something fun that you saw on social
media or like something funny like a
funny video or like a funny Instagram
just show them on your phone yeah it's
not like you're going to show them like
no no I'm allergic to M I can't look at
Instagram but like you know at the same
time skin Fades away
like St melting but I think you know I
think the benefit of being on social
media is you know again it's totally
depends on how you use it but I think
just having that like same even just
like Baseline knowledge of how social
media like memory works and how the
internet works and stuff like that
internet culture works is just a very
nice way to be able to connect to your
partner you know whereas like if you
show them like a [__] meme on
Instagram that has like 70 layers under
it which a lot memes nowadays do have
then it's not going to be really fun
when you show them a meme and they're
like I don't get it you know get I think
in the long run it'll get difficult so
that's why I put beige okay well I think
valid arguments all I don't agree it's a
personal thing you know it's whatever I
mean I I don't need memes to I you know
I I don't I there's more ways to connect
to if I don't show a meme a day I will
die that's all I'm saying Jo's like you
do have the most extensive meme
collection I three of us me yeah I think
so yeah yeah I I gave up I thought it
was you I gave up on memes a while back
actually really well I keep up with them
but I don't I don't collect or make note
of them why why is it a that I collect
memes keep I do not save memes for lot
like you save memes you sh you're yes
you sh I don't share memes anymore I
gave up right oh that's just because I'm
on
Instagram this episode is sponsored by
Mint mobile from billion dollar ad
budgets and Arena naming rights to tens
of thousands of retail locations big
Wireless providers spend big to appear
like they're your only option how do
they afford it all that big Bill you get
every single month mmobile though has a
different idea instead of brick and
mortar overhead mmobile is online only
what does that mean for you a whole lot
of savings that's what it means because
Wireless plans for Mt mobile start at
just $15 a month that's unlimited talk
text and data for just $15 a month I
actually used midmobile before they even
sponsored us when I was in America for a
few weeks I wanted a cheap plan so I
wasn't spending a bunch of money for a
SIM card that I wasn't going to use for
a lot um and mmobile just came up it was
super convenient because everything was
eim so I didn't have to wait in the post
for a Sim to get sent to me and it was
super cheap as well for anyone who hates
their phone bill mmobile offers premium
Wireless which is $15 a month all plans
come with a limited Talk and Text Plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network and you can
use your own phone with any mint Mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts so
to get your new Wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com trash that's
mintmobile.com sltr cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mobile.com trash back to the episode
what's the next
one
uh has watched only basic anime but says
they are a says they are a weeb has
watched basic anime only watched basic
anime and says they're a weeb
okay um
okay okay sure I didn't know have to
think about
it I
mean there's only one answer
right okay ready 3 two 1 I feel
green we all disagree yes I don't give a
[__] this this just shows our
personalities Joey is like anime
mentioned red flag I think there are a
lot of very popular quotequote basic
anime out there where you could actually
be a weeb now and have only watched like
the well-known shows I think you can be
into the anime aesthetic and everything
that like about anime without needing to
watch serial experim experiments Lane
okay but here's the thing this is this
is the insinuation that you use the word
meme in uh wee in a positive way well
what okay I guess that's also a tough
AR referring to yourself as a weeb I
guess I mean you know I'm I'm more like
focusing on the
that paper could have just said calls
themselves a wee it still would have
it's kind of not a very it's not a great
argument but I think that it's whatever
okay the reason I put green is because I
literally uh have met somebody that's
went through this exact scenario like
aan h l and no no it's it's a it's a
friend who's not uh he's not you know of
the he's not on social media yeah he's
not on social media green flag by
basically they they they met a person
and this this person
put in here was one of my close was one
of my close friends and they're a
massive weep right they they went up
through like they went through the phase
where they kind of did the did the anime
man thing where they watched every anime
that came out in a season for like years
on end that's [__] uh and then they
kind of burnt out of anime sure and uh
just like me for real yeah yeah they
just like you for real and they burnt
out anime and they just stopped watching
anime for a long time kind of went on
with life got a job and then they met
their current part
who was like actually I'm a weeb I've
watched my hero Academia and and one
piece not knowing that there's like a
secret level 99 wee standing right next
to them and you know part of the bonding
session that they had and part of the
reason why you know they kind of really
got close together was because she got
to uh introduce them to a bunch of anime
uh not
realizing not like and not realizing
that you know they had they were a
really really big wee is is is one piece
considered Normy now yes
is% sure it is it is very very nor so
you're you're a normie if you such a
horrible word if you watch One Piece
you're making sure okay why you have to
put so much emphasis on the Nory Nory
yeah so like the way I the way I
interpret this that is that okay
enthusiastic yeah they they're
enthusiastic about anime and they've
only seen the basic anime so you have
the opportunity to be the dichotomy of
man you have the opportunity to be like
babe I can I can I can show you the
world I can show you the world babe let
me introduce you to a whole to defend
gatekeeping right okay I will I will say
that is a lovely story but that is one
very rare occurrence in my opinion of it
just happening to work out right okay
most of the time right quote unquote
weaves who have only ever watched my
hero in one piece are not that open to
watching the weird [__] they're not you
don't need to watch the weird [__] Joey
every weeb have watched
Evangelion why Evangelion specifically
it's a great barometer for this kind of
question I think
well anime fans answer very differently
to this question um I think every anime
fan should watch AA not just to like can
they call themselves an anime fan I
don't think they need toy a of course
they can this is going back to the
12-year-old pal thing I don't think you
you need ioy you don't need to watch you
don't need to enjoy AA but you should
watch it if I'm
12-year-old like personally as an anime
fan I I I think every wee should watch
Evangelion just to like have an opinion
on it it's one of those anime where I'm
like it's such a different experience to
everyone who watches it Breaking Bad of
TV fans I would call it that every like
Breaking Bad is like way too critically
acclaimed you know is Evangelion not
it's very polarized I thought it was
very critically acclaimed though no I
think I think it's critically a claim
for the people who love the show but a
lot of people do not like the show and
that's fine but like okay I think for me
the reason why it's red is because I
think the way that I see and you know
act you know act around weebs or like
talk to weebs is very different
considering my background okay because
like when whenever I think of like a
stereotypical weeb like they don't even
have to have watched only the basic [__]
right they could be the most like
knowledgeable in anime but like when
they think that they know a lot about
like Japan or like they know a lot about
like Japanese just because they've
watched a couple hundred shows of anime
couple hundred yeah even a couple
hundred that to me is just
racist
who where are we going with this people
people who only watch anime consume
anime even the most basic [__] and just
think to themselves like yeah I know so
much about Japan I know so much Japanese
in uh interpolating the definition of
weeb as being like probably like um well
I guess weeb is technically like a Japan
yeah it's a japanophile that's what a
weeb is in in the traditional sense and
that's how I do this that angle right
like it would like oh my God if if AI
[__] came up to me every day and
started going and then just started
doing some like maid noises [__] I would
[__] kick her out like that [__]
would be so godamn annoying and there
wouldn't be any room for talking about
hey babe have you watched Evangelion cuz
I wouldn't [__] even ask that
question
I guess I guess if you're Japanese it's
a bit different I
guess of us talking about anime and Jo
just goes
racism I was just like oh my God it is I
I I yeah I'm not Japanese so I can't
take that argument yeah I mean like like
as a counter argument right I think the
like you're taking like I guess the mid
2000s definition of like
wee I love that nuclear response to it
that was great this is kind of content
we need to keep this podcast alive I'm
I'm like somehow I have to argue Against
Racism here but
I'm but hang on but hang on Joey okay
what is the okay okay admittedly yes my
my definition of weeb is like the
[__] yahi paddle ER of Wee right what
is the what what would you say is the
2023 definition of Wee um weeb is I
think like the English language words
always change and I think wee has
changed we doesn't mean someone who's
Japan for me someone who has watched a
lot of anime this this this says someone
has only watched basic anime yeah if
someone's watched a lot of anime they
would never call themselves a weoo
unironically right because they know
about the anime culture when I when I
hear the statement has watch only basic
anime but says they are a wee that means
they are kind of just in the entry level
anime Community kind of thing that that
Pap should say and says they're a wee
not but says they're a wee yeah I mean
those kind of go hand in hand I mean I I
would say if you call yourself a weeb um
and you've watch any basic anime you
just probably heard that as a buzz word
somewhere on the internet like okay
you're just yeah probably probably all
right let's do another take then all
right all right where do we go racism
dude I can't wait for the next take
D you just waiting for my bombastic I
love it dude this is I I'm so glad
someone else are doing it for
once I come swinging we need to keep
this podcast interesting all right next
take red flag green flag or beige flag
uh hasn't watched any classic
movies
uh I don't know how I feel about this
I'm a really big film guy you guys know
I love I think all three of us love film
I'm a b film guy as well we we've all
seen a lot of
movies so I think mine is pretty
straightforward yeah Mine mine's
straightforward as
well I just saw your answer gone what
the [__] it's also it also depends on
how you define classic
movies as well Classic Movies Godfather
okay classic movies I'm going I amdb top
50 all right ready 3 two one I said none
yeah none I don't think it's anything I
think it's whatever green yeah what the
[__] is hold on you're going you think
it's good that they haven't watched the
it's a great trait to have iy I think
it's a [__] great trait just because
you get to like like it's it's very
similar to the anime thing where you get
to show them something and part of like
part of you're assuming that they're
already down to watch them now what if
they're not down to watch what if they
don't want to watch them movie looks old
G yeah what if the reason why they
haven't watched these Classic Movies is
because years ago they looked at the
IMDb top 50 and they're like H they're
all they look old and boring I mean that
that was not said on the piece of paper
to me if someone if someone you're
assuming that they are they they want to
watch them and they're watching with
yeah GH is very optimistic about
optimistic about all these problems okay
I'm super I'm super optimistic I can
change them I can fix them I'm I'm super
optimistic because uh I just love like
not even like with your partner but like
with any friends or family that I have
plenty of family members who you know
have not watched X thing or have not
experienced X thing and part of that
especially if it's a partner I I like to
me it's a green flag because I assume if
we're Partners right that part of part
of being a partner is that even if
you're not necessarily interested in a
topic that you're you know that before
you met your partner that you want to
explore it with them like for me I do
not give a [__] about horror movies for
example but I still will sit down with
Sydney and watch some horror movies and
I'm happy just seeing the stuff that
she's passionate about even though I'm
not I'm never going to be as passionate
about it right but again you're you're
looking at this like you know fictional
relationship that you have with this
partner as a very optimistic thing of
like they're just kind of down for
everything and the only reason they
haven't watched these Classic Movies is
because they've just never given the
opportunity well why you why are you
being pessimistic Joey what's wrong with
being a little bit optimistic about
assuming the best of intention because
life's a [__] it doesn't work out that
way it's not all candy and rainbow
sometimes there are people who are just
so up in their own head where they look
at some they look at these like movies
like Godfather like Apocalypse Now like
Good Fellas and they just like oh it's
old and it was made before my time not
interested I don't care I'd rather watch
the next [__] Avengers movie watch
the FNAF film I'd rather watch a FNAF
film you know to me if if if the paper
said that uh they' watched a bunch of
classic films and they do not care for
them that would be like a different
answer for me what would that be for you
uh for me no for me that would be more
like more beige nun you know like to me
that doesn't signify a relationship but
to me if I know someone has not seen the
same things that I'm interested in I see
that as an opportunity to be like oh
okay we can bond together or I can show
you stu that I'm passionate about and
I'm interested in and we don't
necessarily need to enjoy the same
things to have a good good working
relationship so because you could
reframe this with anything like um they
haven't read the classic books they
haven't read watched the K K drama
series the classics why that's why I
said none though in this case because
it's like it can really go both ways and
if you kind of average that all out it
does become a nonf flag yeah I think
it's whatever like I think there's a
reason why you haven't consumed that
media there's lots of people out there
like to see the good in people I like to
assume the best guys you're like like
it's great cuz then I can share it with
them again that is
great all right all right pick one pick
oneck all sorry ladies G's
Tak all right is G just going to write
green for
everything all right what's the next one
G doesn't watch a show if it's
popular
okay all
right why are you guys laughing no
reason no reason Joey all right I got M
all right three two
one I mean I think it's I think it's a
bad trait to have some might say I mean
if if if you're just judging Things
based on its popularity uh then like
you're not coming into this with a open
mind you're coming in this with
preconceive you're just hater you're a
hater yeah you're just you're just a
hater and you think you have better
taste and more Superior taste I'm not
speaking on behalf of anyone but if I
was someone like that uh you think it
was an odity I think it's just a bit
weird and there's yeah I think it's a
red flag weird what if you know we were
dating Joey and I was super happy to
watch this new show called Arcane with
you and I was telling you about how
super excited for it and you're like no
we're not watching it no I'll watch it
like 5 years later no
okay well it's we're getting there do
you promise to watch Arcane in 3 years
no wait you just said you'll watch it 5
years later no just some amount of flag
that's my red flag dude I'm currently
watching [__] stranger things cuz I'm
finally getting around to finishing it
and it's great all right all right I'll
pick all right all right all
right well I know Felix has my back I'm
not the only one I'll say that to Felix
as well Joey it's okay this episode is
sponsored by vessie all right so I was
taking a walk the other day and you know
it had been raining a bit but I didn't
pay much attention and then I just
stepped into the biggest puddle of all
time because I wasn't looking where I
was walking wet socks are the worst but
you know what it was okay cuz I was
actually wearing my vessie so my feet
were bone dry that's right rain sleep
snow or shine it doesn't matter vess's
is perfect for any occasion during any
season and they've come out with some
absolutely amazing stuff I you guys know
trash taste we're massive fans of vess
we only wear versies look at this
amazing Soho sneaker well Connor I know
you are absolutely going to fall in love
with these because they are 100%
waterproof with diatex technology and a
synthetic leather exterior these are
some simple shoes perfect for any
occasion but Joey they also have the
altar right here that's right these are
a little bit better for the colder times
of the year so if you want to look fly
as hell in the snow then you better grab
yourself these Ulta shoes it also seems
that I'm wearing some vessie gloves too
I also have this Co he just keeps coming
flexible stretchy and breathable you of
stop con don't miss so if you're eager
to snag the best deals in footwear go to
vy.com trashtaste right now because they
have a big sale going on the sale is
going on from the 17th of November to
the 27th of November so get on it now
Lads back to the episode all right what
do what do you got big piece of
paper we should probably audibly say
what we have out so the audio listeners
can keep up that's what I've been saying
uh uses astr ology
unironically uses astrology
unironically
okay God I'm so glad I'm taken I would I
probably seem like the most unattractive
person right now you know what you want
Jerry there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that I know I
want all right say what your answer is
on three 2 1 red red red yeah we can all
okay look this
this is just a dude answer I I think
every single dude watching this episode
right now can agree sorry ladies it's
just like when something goes wrong and
then someone tells me yeah it's just not
a good month for Leos and I'm like I'm
like I will I will kill you and then
they'll be like that is what a Leo would
say I'm like I will I cannot express how
much I hate that you think that one in
12 people are exactly the same and can
be interpreted by the movements of
[__] science just start belly
laughing like that it's it's some of the
funniest pseudo science out there and I
really hope it doesn't stop cuz it never
gets it's also just frustrating to for
me when I feel like it is okay to admit
that we just don't know things as as a
population that we just don't have it
figured out and and I hate that it is
trying to give some agency to give
people a a feeling that they know it but
I feel like knowing nothing is better
than knowing something completely
incorrect people are weird and there's
no Rhyme or you know reason into it
sometimes and you can't like you can't
pigeonhole them into like a specific
like trait or month or whatever not how
it works I mean there's like different
levels of this cuz there are some people
that base their entire lives around do
it for yourself for fun but if you start
bringing into every into that my life
into it I think the important word here
is uses astrology unironically cuz I
know plenty of people there just like to
have fun with it and that's [__] fun
I love using it ironically cuz it pisses
people off
and it's so funny seeing their reactions
cuz it's like that's how I react when
some someone says it unironically and
it's really funny yeah I think uh if if
you if you use it and you're not like
pushing that [__] on me it's fine but um
I also don't want you to I also get
concerned if like your life is going to
[__] and you're like well I guess it's
just cuz Mercury's in retrograde yeah no
what are you talking about yeah it's
it's like I I think like the planet
doesn't give a [__] about your feelings
yeah for for me like the like the male
equivalent to like astrology is just the
[__] like stock Bros and crypto Bros
who who are just like
yeah listen listen dud we we've been
very harsh this is a very generally
female uh fale such a horrible word you
know leaning towards more uh feministic
kind of Le our experience yeah we could
have been like oh they trade stocks we'
been like [__] red green bro they're
so sick trade I've had a bad day Bitcoin
wi down two points you know I think that
yeah we we we've been we've we we have
we have have our own viic as well that
are equally as I think red
flaggy but shout out to the dudes who
use astrology by the way no no you are
you are the minority and uh it's
hilarious keep please keep doing it
let's let's uh let's not use it un
ironically let's just keep it for fun
like any kind of like Po like
personality test or anything like that r
j that's that's what like kids who are
getting bullied at school she used to
retort okay well I don't why am I being
bullied Leo because that's that's the
real Leo energy you're giving me right
now you need to stall all right next one
uh uh having an obsession example Disney
adult just any Obsession it's okay yeah
we the Disney adult so an adult obsessed
with Disney is an example but just
having an obsession well well okay how
do we want to do this I can we stick to
just Disney okay being a Disney adult
cuz Obsession everyone has an obsession
yes of course but we're talking about
specific obsessions here phrase then
green flag red flag Disney
adult I I don't know why I did this okay
I'll tell you what I just did by
accident um oh God so so the qu the
question now is is a Disney adult a red
flag is a Disney adult a red flag or
green flag for you as a bro going to be
in The Gallows if he answers this
wrong three two one red what what the
[__] is it actually a [__] Disney
adult Roy is not a Disney
adult she is she's a Disneyland every
goddamn Joey how many times objection I
see I'll pull up on Instagram right now
was she within Disney in the past week
yeah okay I rest my case but I will come
here to defend my girlfriend first of
all she only goes to Disney a couple of
times a year OB should cop your H which
I think is fine I know because that's
the days I avoid second of all she's not
a Disney fan she's a Kingdom Hearts fan
which automatically wor objection it's
worse your honor agree I will agree on
that but I think like my definition of a
Disney adult right and I've met some
actual Disney adults are people who like
say for example you live outside of the
States you go to California right
there's a Disneyland there perfect if
you're in Disneyland every single
[__] day or multiple days in a row
that's a Disney adult I think where like
everything around your house is Disney
themed you only watch Disney movies you
like deep dive into like the Disney law
and there are lots of people like that
to me that's a red flag I think there's
nothing wrong with liking Disney there
or like liking Disney movies I like a
lot of Disney movies and you know I
don't like Disneyland in general just
cuz I don't like amusement parks right
but I think liking Disney there is
nothing wrong with a Disney adult is
something on another level okay what if
okay okay but akie is like
swear this is the Charlie Day image of
Joey like let me explain to you why Aki
is not a Disney is not a Disney at all
listen she would be offended if you
called her a Disney adult she could
become one very easily which is why I'm
here to stop her okay okay I'm showing
her Classic Movies you would be you
would be unhappy with akie if she went
further down the Disney par yeah and she
knows that the You' had this you had
this honey you have to stop no I
straight up said to her I'm like you can
go to Disneyland with your friends
that's fine just chill out a little
bit watch a couple of other warnings
boundaries have i' said look I'm a very
straightforward person if I think you're
going to become a Disney adult I will
tell you um yeah I mean my reasoning is
that like I don't like Disney I don't
like what they do that's fair uh I think
that basing your whole personality
around their movies is a rapid way to
spend your life on on this time on this
planet which does not she has a lot of
other likes and wants and you know a lot
of other obsessions Disney is just one
of them am I one to talk I played League
of Legends for seven years so I maybe I
shouldn't that that would definitely be
a red flag agree
um I just don't like how Disney does
what Disney does uh and I think that
people I hate how they do business I
hate it they're they're they're are evil
corate they're so evil they're so and
they they they dominate they they [__]
people over but I disy straight up also
the new movies suck I'm just gonna say
it right now all movies suck live action
remakes that they keep pushing I'm not a
fan can we stop doing this not a single
one of their remakes have been good uh I
think they're terrible all all they've
been doing I hate Disney plus I Hate
Everything it stands for I think we have
too many subscriptions uh and I'm glad
that they lost the rights to the cricket
in India so they so they lost that
market yeah they did they had could you
imagine you wanted to watch cricket
ninja you got to [__] s to Disney
plus um I I you're watching the Disney
Channel I just hate Disney I think that
like I I I don't know man they they just
feel like a bully as well as a company
oh yeah the fact that they wouldn't let
a guy famously have a Spider-Man
Tombstone for his his uh young kid who
died of a disease and they they gave him
a cease and deist to remove the
Spider-Man wait did they actually yeah
yeah that's [__] up um I feel like
they're just cruel I don't like Disney's
a company and then I feel like basing
your whole personality off of just a
company is bizarre yeah that is true
would you say the same thing about
Nintendo though 100% yeah Nintendo
adults are like a different breed
they're like the same kind of thing like
if you like like if you are unironically
like Kirby you should end your life you
should not be allowed to
vote you know Nintendo Bros and uh
Disney princesses have a a lot in common
you know let me okay let me say one word
maybe they should end up with each other
let me okay there is one thing that you
red flag or green flag Nintendo with the
the happy go-lucky suing uh is is
encroaching on like Disney levels dude
as a Nintendo fan there I said it as a
Nintendo fan I think that's also [__]
up and I absolutely do not stand by that
I think you know the fact that they are
incredibly hypocritical with that [__]
as well you know like the fact that like
the Wii Virtual Console like retro games
later found out to all be emulated Yeah
well yeah they they and they straight up
re uploaded somebody's emulation of the
original Super Mario Brothers vir cons I
think was just abely hilarious so I
think yes as aan I think Nintendo has
done some really shitty things to do
some really shitty things I just [__]
love their games no the games are great
and that's that's the same Disney I
don't I don't think a lot of Disney like
adults think that deeply about it I'm
sure even some of them are like aware of
the business practices yeah but I think
if you're going to sign your life away
and your whole personality to a brand
you should at least be aware of the
brand oh for sure and I think Nintendo
it's that constant like like God damn it
he he's a dick but man he he's so fun to
have
around you know that's the vibe Nintendo
gives off yeah um that's the reason why
everyone the games are great yeah my
answer is not that deep I was just like
I've just never liked Disney stuff so
I'm probably not going to Vibe with this
person if they're going to be a life
partner yeah a lot of a lot of people
also Bas the whole personality around
Disney are a little bit obnoxious
sometimes too but I also know some
Disney adults who are absolutely chill
and very nice people but I just
personally no absolutely and I think
like again there's nothing wrong with
being a Disney adult as long as you
actually have some like other things to
[__] talk about it Obsession should
be in moderation whether it be Disney
whether it be Nintendo whatever it might
be and uh if you really really like
Disney but you also like a lot of other
things which Ary does I don't think
there's anything wrong with it yeah I
mean I think it's hard to draw the line
of where that's not a Disney
adult listen there is a reason why we
have the word Disney adult everyone
knows what that means because that
someone who only likes Disney there's no
there's no anime adult there's no uh
we yeah but a weave we are we not anime
adults no because it's a different vibe
the word Disney adult gives us a very
different feeling to the word
weeb yes Disney adult is I would always
consider is it because when you say the
word weeb you imagine like a 12-year-old
oh we you just imagine like someone
who's a casual anime fan like when I hit
Disney adult I think I picture the Karen
cutting in line just being like this is
the perfect route to the Disney theme
park we have to do this no that's just a
Karen who's in Disney that's
yeah um I I mean I I guess we kind of
like narrowed down the wording of this
but I guess a lot of what we said could
be applied to anyone with like a massive
Obsession I guess the the the general
thing is that this more is well known
with Disney adults Disney they are the
loud minority for sure well I don't know
about minority there's a lot of them
well in the grand someone's buying these
the grandest scale of the human race
they are the minority all right well
let's do the next one this episode is
sponsored by Holz gun founded as a small
family business in Austria all of their
products are partially made from natural
materials their grains allow for every
product to be truly unique they started
with watches and then extended to
jewelry sunglasses and a whole lot more
I mean check out these watches right
here all sunglasses that where did you
get that from sorry guys I'm cool with
my purse as well look at that purse that
purse is made entirely from wood yeah
honestly I love a lot of these jewelries
and the watches if you want to get a bit
of wood in your lives girl look at look
at how look at this stuff un ironically
though my favorite is the purse yeah
that that's just really sick if you want
like a nice like Christmas gift uh for
your significant other that's a little
bit different from the norm why not get
them one of these oo hone is doing a
Black Friday special from November 14th
until November the 20th if you buy one
then you can get one more at 50% off oh
my gosh so if you want to get some
uniquely designed pieces that have a bit
of nature on yourself you should go and
get some Holk head on over to hc.com
trashtaste that's hc.com / traste links
in the description below all right
where' you get G all
right uh never been in a long-term
relationship wait this this this CH like
if they're like 18 you're like well good
if they're like 50 you're like okay
never been in a long-term relationship
the age age matters so much our okay
okay let's assume from now on that
what's on median age this is this is
something that we are finding out on a
first date that we're on I think I'm
medium AG right so it' be like 29 say 30
right 30 okay 30 years old never been in
a long consider relationship what is
long what is the definition of a long
relationship I'd say like a year a year
plus yeah year plus at least a year okay
um o that's an interesting one never
been in a long-term and we're not
counting someone who's just never been
in a relationship in general right uh
are we counting that cuz I feel like I
mean
like you can have a 30-year-old who's
never been in a relationship I think
it's I think actually it's very
different though being in many
relationships as opposed to being in
that's what I'm saying so like are we
including that no I wouldn't include
that so they've been in relationships
before but none of them have lasted
longer than a year I'm going yeah I'm
going into this it because they've never
had a longterm which implies they've had
relationship sure okay um oh this is
tough okay I'm going to
go never been in a long-term
relationship what's the body count
well we can discuss this what's the body
count what's the body what's the body
count I'm kidding I'm kidding uh this is
tough yeah this is hard all right all
right let me this is a very very nuanced
argument okay I think I got my answer
all right Connie got yours okay ready
three two one I said none none I said
red you said red okay well let's let's
start off with you you're 30 years old
yeah presumably you've been in mul we
pres here all the things I'm presuming
I'm assuming before we start yeah you 30
years old you've been in multiple
relationships none have made it to a
year yeah um who's the common
denominator
here what if that person say example
your partner right what if she was just
with seven really [__] boyfriends I
think the odds of that happening are so
much lower than you I
think listen I hate to be this person if
you if you've been with seven [__]
people I think you're the [__] person in
the you're the that is true you know
like think about it like whenever you
hear about someone cuz I think we all
have that one friend who has been in so
many relationships but never had
something solid and you're like you're
like after a while you're like man there
must be something that you're kind of
like not giving here or not
understanding about a relationship that
I think is give and take sure I think a
lot of people you just sometimes you
people in life who just aren't very good
at like compromising and and doing that
kind of stuff um I can change them
that's why I wrote n listen I think I
think n me baby you won't need I wasn't
the comment actually I think n is the
safe answer but I'm I'm trying to be
like I'm trying to stir a conversation
I'm the equal side
this I'm thinking like from my
perspective if they've never been in one
I would be like okay I want to know
what's going on here cuz I think it's a
red flag is in like not like this is bad
I'm not going to talk to them more like
this is something that I want to kind of
pick their brain about more and figure
out what's Happening Here
it would definitely be something that I
would want to know about their past
relationships and like what happened so
that I can figure out like oh okay this
could be an issue going forward or like
I can understand that they weren't
willing to compromise on this or they
can tell you the person because some
people genely have just been with awful
people and they've been in like I you
know I've been in a bad relationship for
a long time you just get stuck in these
things but I think I'd love to talk
about it more yeah and I I say R but
it's it's not really yeah and I think
that's why I said none cuz like it
really is it's like a pink flag it's not
red as in like I'm not doing it but I'm
like I definitely want to know what's up
yeah it's like it's such a case by case
scenario with like every single person
there there is like there doesn't have
people who not dating At All by the way
yeah this like if I hear that it's kind
of like it does raise a flag it raises a
flag of like context what's what's the
context what's going on here yeah um
because it could it could be none and uh
you know it could be green it could be
red we don't know what the context of it
can really slant on the entire
Spectrum it can really SL on the entire
Spectrum depending on like you know some
sure you know in a very low you know
case scenario it might just be the fact
that they just got really unlucky with
their Partners who were all [__] or the
more common scenario is that their [__]
right I mean yeah relationships are
tough a lot of the time you're probably
just doing something small that that
adds up over time that's how
allation right yeah I mean it's all
about communication I think like another
reason why it might not mean anything at
all or it's just like maybe their
previous relationships they just weren't
at the right stage of life to really
fully commit you know some people are
just like actually I want to commit to
uh my career right now and I don't have
time for relationships go out there find
yourself you know yeah yeah and then
they they regen maybe it's cuz I'm like
the 30y old so if I hear that I'm like
okay this is about the age that I've met
around my friends where people are like
something like switches in their brain
to be like all right maybe I should
start you realize you know you got to
start you got to start figuring this
[__] out soon if you if you want to um
have children cuz you know you know you
get past 40 it becomes kind of kind of
tough so you got to you got start
figuring that stuff out pretty soon
absolutely yeah it's part of the being
all right well that one was that one
there was no definite answer in that one
but good want to talk about it we got we
got to talk about disc call me filter
Frank because I want to jump right into
it I'm like let's figure out what's
going on all right just want to talk I
just want to talk I just want to talk
let's talk about it all right next up
what do we got
uh believes in
superstitions oo believes in
superstitions
um jeez I guess this is to like what
extent I feel like some everyone has
like a one Superstition they believe in
but I feel like let's let's say we're
going to assume this is like they are
very into superstitions very into
Superstition I would say more than
normal okay then my answer is going to
change
cuz I think everyone has like a lot's
what's more than normal name me a
scenario you you're just never going to
feel good about someone open an umbrella
inside and that's right you try and open
up an umbrella inside they're like no no
no yeah yeah but like that's a normal
that's generally quite normal in Western
countries so that's more of like a
conditioning thing than as opposed to
like actually believing that something
horrible is about to go wrong so I think
that yeah so basically I thought it was
like ghosts and shanes superstitions
yeah superstitions means
no superstitions means like you believe
in something that might happen when
there is no physical evidence step on a
crack break your mother's back break
your mother bad which is absolutely
ridiculous he could have chose something
better but believe that [__] when I was
like four uh all right all right okay I
think I think we're all going to say the
same thing here okay ready 3 two one
beig quirky thing I don't have a lot to
say about this other than
sure this is just all Japanese people
yeah Japanese
people way too much to the point where
like you know I could be at my aunt's
house I try and open up an umbrella and
she'll be like oh don't think that's a
good idea and I'm like why I mean I mean
I mean this is I mean this is a lot of
Asian households there are a lot of
weird Asian superstitions I don't know
how many Western superstitions there are
you know uh step on a crack breaking
mothers back I remember that one uh what
is it a ladder and doors is it no if a
black cat crosses your path then it's
bad luck or something walking underneath
a ladder or walking underneath a ladder
smart
safety yeah I wonder where the black cat
came from cuz like I think it just came
from the idea of like you know uh at
least in Japan I think where it came
from was like you know a black cat is
the same color as a crow and crows are
usually not a great symbol you know like
symbol of death and stuff like that so I
think it's just also also you know cats
I think were always like just a target
for super superstitions ever since like
you know people used to call each other
witches back in the day being like Oh
you own a cat you must be a witch cuz I
feel like all superstitions come from
somewhere you know because like I don't
know if it okay here's usually from
someone just smoking crack here's the
thing like I don't I think every
Superstition c l of here's the thing
like I don't know if there been like
something that's conditioned into me but
like most superstitions are kind of like
I don't believe in them but I do agree
that they're not good vibes you know
like the energy
is a positive
Superstition uh gener no no no no
everything is based on something and
that's something I don't I I'm pretty
sure it just something about bad vibes
you know I don't believe anything that's
is going to happen when you open an
umbrella inside but I see an umbrella
that's open inside I'm like oo I I don't
I don't I don't I don't like this I
don't like I don't like this I don't
know why I just don't like it you know I
don't I don't like it it's just
unnatural yeah and when you like walk
and like maybe this my ADHD but when I
notice that I'm stepping on cracks I'm
just like what if I just what if like
what I my mom what if what what what if
the smooth part of my brain is just like
oo but what if I step in between the
cracks you know you know what I mean you
know it's like the [__] I used to do
when I was like five exactly exactly it
just feels when it's like a tiled
flooring and you're just like stepping
on a perfect like Step Mania sh feels
nicer to like like once you like
consciously observe it oh totally yeah
yeah I I get it I get it superstitious
people I it's just a bit weird but it's
not a deal breaker yeah all right let's
see let's let's check out the next
one all right here we go all right what
flag is uh a partner that can't handle
losing as in they're a sore
loser um all
right s loser all
right three all right two one red red
red red oh we're all red okay okay I
mean yeah it's uh s loser is just never
a positive thing that's that's not even
a partner thing that's a red that's a
red flag as a uh as a friend losing
going you got to lose yeah losing is how
you get better the worst thing about a
soul loser is just how much of a Vibe
killer they become I that's the worst
part I the thing I hate more than people
who hate losing are people who won't
even try cuz they don't want to lose at
something that's the thing I hate the
most when like you won't even play
something cuz you know you're not going
to win and that thus you're not going to
play and then You' be like this is
[__] stupid anyway so it's whatever I
hate that so much no no like the thing
the thing I think that is like even
worse than that because no no one likes
losing or anything but when when I hear
someone that hates losing right if you
have to if you hate losing there's
there's I've been enough around enough
people where they lose at something and
they kind of just like shut down as a
human being they're just pissed and they
want to bring the vibe down because they
are having an awful time for losing at
some kind of game or something I want to
go again like let me play again I'll
beat you this time double or nothing I
don't know I just it's F it's fun
getting better at stuff why would you
not want to get better at something well
just some people just want to be just
perfect at everything you know and they
want to look like the perfect human and
just life doesn't work that way to me
maybe it's not someone who hates losing
someone who's a sore loser that is that
is such a big vibe
I but I'm I'm not going to throw a strop
about it and like let's [__] play
again let's go no yeah for sure all
right all right well that one was pretty
unanimous oh that was that was pretty
that was pretty easy though that was
pretty easy who who thinks man that's
sexy is sexy when they want love when
someone love when they get pissed off a
little bit damn all
right uh keeps relationship private oh
uh I'm guessing in what context uh I'm
guessing just they kind of like separate
their relationship to kind of like other
aspects of their lives so so they're you
know someone who kind of like hangs out
with their friends oh like when you're
like you're hanging around a friend and
then he's like oh by the way I've been
in a relationship for like eight months
you're like what yeah yeah yeah like
that or or like more more like you know
they hang out with their friends and
they just don't like talk about their
partner at all or um oh as in like they
keep their relationship
out ofs
that so so you know that if you're
dating the opposite of that would be
someone who's like oh yeah that was
really cool by the way my boyfriend
someone is constantly just like pushing
in their own so so so the way I
interpret this is okay so you're dating
someone yeah they will never talk to you
uh they will never talk about you to
their friends outside of oh outside of
is that the context you guys meant with
this
one yeah yeah yeah okay okay okay okay
I'm trying to discern like I said not a
lot of work with yeah um I don't really
have crazy okay
um oh man this is
hard so they don't go out of their way
to talk about their relationship to
other people yeah and just so I guess
what if okay but what if like someone
comes up to that person and is like
how's your boyfriend or girlfriend and
they talk about it is that I think a
normal thing is just like someone who
just doesn't really mention you kind of
like unnecessarily unnecessarily this is
such a Vibe check kind of thing it's so
hard to know yeah I guess I guess this
very much keeps relationship private cuz
I could see multiple different
people who have this kind of thing and
it would be very very different with
each person how the vi would it really
depends on the personality but cuz like
there's like Jeffrey Dharma kind of
private or you're like oh and then
you're like you know that was the worst
example you know some of you're like
that's why is he keeping it so private
that's so concerning you know I'd
understand if my boyfriend was a serial
killer but you know it'd be a little bit
more understanding they they got high
literally all right I'm ready all ready
3 2 1 none none yeah I don't this is
such a case by case it's whatever you
know like if if Ari wants to go around
[__] talking about me to her
girlfriends or doesn't at all I it
doesn't really change my [__] thing I
didn't even think of this from like my
perspec I think from like friend's
perspective like if if da didn't talk
about Sydney ever I would be like well
think about it with your part oh I don't
think I'd care that much I would care I
care I feel like as long as you as long
as you uh they know I exist right you're
the family right they know I'm real
right I'm a real boyfriend yeah yeah I
mean like there's plenty of reasons to
want to separate your love life from
like other aspects of your life um and
there's some reason who really want to
shout to the world about their love life
and I respect both I don't really care
seriously how you do it yeah about
posing I think yeah I think there's a
right way to do it and there's a
definitely a wrong way to do it yeah
what what I what I think is a red flag
is uh kind of like someone who
unprompted says every little intimate
part of like their relationship to like
everyone it's like yeah this meal is
great but it kind of reminds me of the
time my boyfriend [__] me in the ass
you know like it's like whoa all right I
didn't even know that
next uh believes in conspiracy
theories okay okay well this is
I hope to God we all have the same
answer for this 3 2 1 it's reded it's
red it's a very very concerning trait to
not be able to discern like [__]
online yeah and in general yeah I feel
that's just someone who is incredibly
gullible to a dangerous level and that
can sneak into all other parts of the
relationship that could be dangerous I I
don't even think it's gullible man I
just think it's like a it's we live in a
really tough time yeah where I think a
lot of people uh you fall for a lot of
things I'm sure we all have fallen for
something at some point one or another
but it's about being able to like
educate yourself and know when you're
when you're wrong and learn when you've
been fed misinformation or [__] um I
want to date a freethinking person not a
sheep all right well you know a lot of
people I wake up sheep a lot of people I
care about my life i' found out when
they they'd say something I'm like oh no
you you believe something that is wrong
and this is I don't know how to feel
about this food poisoning is not an
illness well that's that's not that's
not a theory joke it's the truth okay I
wake
up it it kind of depends on uh like if I
heard this instant like my gut feeling
is a red flag uh obv not even just as a
partner just as someone I want to be
associated with you yeah yeah yeah it's
it's like a big thing is that how how
big of conspiracy are we talking here
are we talking about cuz there's lots of
like little conspiracies where it
doesn't have like that much of an effect
on the way that someone thinks about the
last thing that I can think about that
really kind of tested this was uh the co
vaccine like a lot of a lot of people
when it came out right like cuz a lot of
people that's true when it initially
came out they were like oh I just don't
know if I feel good about a vaccine that
was made so fast yeah which was a
sentiment that was very very popular um
and and it made this really weird thing
with people who normally would never
like be conspiratorial kind of got
reading kind of pieces online that kind
of more aligned with that theory and
reasons why and it was a really like
kind of sad time really where a lot of
people that was the day where everyone
collectively cleaned out their like
Facebook friends closet it was it was it
was a really like I know immediately it
was a really like [__] up time and I
think that it was like the perfect storm
to get people who would never never like
think this kind of way who would kind of
go down some rabbit holes they wouldn't
have gone down um it was just sad that
just made me sad yeah yeah yeah I mean I
think like I said it very much depends
on the level of what kind of conspiracy
are they believing in is it something
like [__] flat earthers or something
like that g chips 5G chips okay
obviously red flag is it something a bit
more fun like oh there are aliens in
like Area 51 or something like that you
know which is believe that you can be
okay all right red flag based on facts
from the Navy seen it you can you can
talk about conspiracy theories in a fun
fun way yeah but if seriously believing
a lot of these things is I think is just
bad and dangerous as well if especially
if you're going to have kids and going
tell them this [__] abely going to make
other kids who are [__] totally yeah
yeah I I think it's one thing to
entertain the thought of conspiracy
theories it's another thing to like
fully commit to it yeah uh oh we only
got a few left in here might have to
stock up soon we're going through these
way too fast no I I have all right next
one
uh they like horror to much I put this
one in yeah I can see
why I G and I feel a Target on our backs
right now wow this is this is a personal
attack this is this is a goddamn
personal
attack brother in arms all right I hope
we make the right answer 3 2 1
B let's go I said red you said Reds okay
for me again this is another one of it
depends this is exactly like the Disney
adult it just depends on how much right
you can like a lot of horror movies
which Sydney and Ari most certainly do
love the horror genre right love the
True Crime [__] I think that's fine but
when once you start to get to the point
of like you know you're actively trying
to like pursue cases or like you know
you love like the absolutely like
abhorrent like Gore porn type films that
you can only find on the black market
and [__] that's a red flag for me right
right but if you just like horror as a
genre I think it's fine oh this is like
pure no reason just feeling I'm like I
just don't like I I just get a bad Vibe
why personally why well I hey I like
Sydney Sydney's great but when I'm when
I'm like if I'm talking to someone and
they're like the most lovely people I
know are hor big hor
fans metal heads of the horor the other
one is John super I wolf you know
[__] not me as like a red flag as
people I'm like to date someone who
likes horror too much for me I just
don't [__] with the vibe do you not like
horror I think it's like the worst genre
overall really consistently it gets the
worst [__] I mean there's a lot of [__]
horror films out there it's one of the
easiest types of films genre for genre
It generally has like the lowest quality
of most things because I mean there
there's a lot of reasons why you know
what I'm going to come here and defend
horror you can okay as a genre
I'm as as a genre yes I agree that uh
there are a lot of [__] horror films and
they are happen to be the ones that get
the most uh marketing and the most
attention like the FNAF film that just
came out for example but I'd say as a
genre horror has some of the most
conceptually interesting ideas you can
find in anywhere like most genres which
is why I'm a [__] [__] but I'm one
of those kinds of guys who I love
hearing about horror movies cuz I like
to experience horror without experience
hor experiencing horror movies cuz they
have such interesting
ideas I am also a [__] uh but some of
the really good horror films I've
watched I've just absolutely loved as a
film just because it's so like I'm not
here out B saying this no good horror
films I'm just saying film for film no I
I I totally agree with that and I think
the problem there you're treating this
like a [__] UFC fight yo pound for
pound pound for pound show me the genre
sci-fi dog [__] genre someone tally it
up dog [__] no I totally agree like I
think you know because of like the whole
b-grade horror thing and just the fact
that horror as a story and as a type of
film is probably one of the easier
genres to film for like Indie creators
and like you know Indie directors and
stuff like that yes there is a lot of
[__] out there a lot of really amateur
[__] that's boring and stereotypical but
whenever you get some like really
conceptually different and just like
thrilling and well-written stories in
the
this more an extension of my hatred for
the most popular well not hatred but you
know I I admitt I consume this but I I
hate that I consume this stuff and I
hate that what True Crime stuff yeah I
hate I hate the yeah true crime is the
most popular horror genre right now oh
yeah but you can't look away no yeah but
it's like it it feels like there's
really I and I always say this all the
time it feels I don't it makes me feel
weird I don't like that we I mean I I
said that right like at the first
[__] remember this he a trans this
one I said it before it was like super
popular now people are like oh it's it's
super popular you hate it now I'm
kidding how do feel
no it's just personal experience every
person that I've ever been with who is
very into horror bad vibes bad vibes bad
vibes for me personally I'm also the
commom yeah for me for me when I when I
see someone like that uh I don't I don't
think bad vibes I just think man they
are very morbidly curious and um um you
know it's it's that a lot of the times
The Morbid curiosity just takes over the
logical brain because they know it's
like a lot of people who I've met know
it's just like ah I you know I know I
shouldn't look at this should been a
plague doctor back in the
day yeah probably and she would have
loved it yeah like to me to me I'm not
someone who's that morbidly curious I've
seen enough things to be like ah I think
my day would be happy if I didn't see
this one thing that's good beig beig me
it's just a little quirky yeah to me to
me it's just like one weird thing that
someone obsesses over if they're not
hurting anyone over it then I think it's
fine yeah difference a Disney adult and
a horror fanatic yeah oh my Lord to me
the Disney thing is mostly I think like
the Disney thing is more in line of with
why you put red as horror just not my
vibes it's this is like cuz I think if
you would have we could have a genuine
conversation about like why all of these
are really not that bad yet but I I feel
like we should be going off pure gut
like how we're feeling about it yeah
okay because that's how it should be
because this is your you're imagine
you're dating this person like I would
just son my go I don't have to imagine
yeah of my balls would tell me don't
date the Disney adult I don't know why I
just wouldn't feel good about it I mean
I have no problem with being a Disney
adult I have no problem Mary being a
horror fanatic uh she just likes Kingdom
Hearts a little too much in my opinion
that's a red flag all right let's uh on
all right all right here we
go swear to God Different Strokes for
different f it should be personal
reference yeah it's all
good what do we got users twitch emotes
in
conversation uh
okay uh oh god well technically copium
is a twitch emote yeah I know yeah yeah
there's a lot of twitch em all right
ready three two one red red okay if it's
a friend no problems with it it's
whatever I'm on a first dat with someone
they say pogies to me I'm or oooo
anything like that I'm like all right
I'm out yeah yeah this restaurant I'm
it's Ki W right now yeah yeah you know
if if I'm if I'm in sleep I guess if I'm
in any kind of situation other than a
[__] like twitch con or like an anime
convention if I'm talking to streamers
or something yeah if I go on Tinder and
we get in the conversation and they
unironically use a twitch emote I'm like
no I didn't think I didn't think I would
get a reply back
mon then I'm like all right in Swip like
what that shows me is this person is
terminally online which of course they
are like us uh one I kind of want to get
away from that and two uh I don't even I
I rarely even use twitch emotes even
though it's like our job in like our
conversation it's pogers yeah pogers is
just every time every time Connor says
like a twitch emote most of the time I
tell him to shut the [__] up I value
being able to be a social chameleon
right I like being able to if you throw
me in a in a dinner with a bunch of
Stuffy Bankers I could probably I could
probably have some conversations there
and I would love to see that they
wouldn't they wouldn't know you know
that I'm a twitch streamer I think I I'd
be completely fine for purple shirt wear
OB be wearing something different I'd
wearing something different if I wanted
to fit and I could and and I value being
able to be able to fit in whichever
scenario cuz if you come in right first
dat you're going pogies oh this food is
uh is pogers and then I'm thinking like
man when I introduce him to my parents
this is going to be
tough you know what I mean like I have
I'm thinking about
that it's I'm thinking long games come
on like I I you know I can't be like
don't [__] say Kappa once during this
dinner okay I don't want to have to have
that conversation it's like so so how
just imagine like the boyfriend's
parents talking to the girlfriend saying
like so how is he treating you it's like
here to go no cap yeah it's pretty it's
pretty it's pretty Pepe hands right now
it's it's just like if if they think Big
W not like this no way if they if they
think way yeah if if they think that you
know it's socially acceptable on like a
first date to just start spamming the
twitch emotes IRL um like to the street
I'm imag the streets I'm imagining to
the chat with you I'm imagining what
kind of like situations would they also
be comfortable spamming twitch emotes
like what if belongs in the chat what if
what if we're not she goes pogies yeah
yeah yeah what if we're in
bed yo that was a gold split right there
no way Ain't No Way Ain't No Way ain't
no
way that sounds [__] horrible yeah
thank God when they see my three- inch
amkus ain't no way no in general though
I have um it doesn't just like I guess
stop at twitch emotes if they start like
pumping out the Discord memes in like
everyday conversation you know we we we
we got to have a chat we got to have a
chat as well did you come
sus feel like get off of me the word
come has been ruined for me I always get
like in my head there's that Split
Second someone says come I'm like I'm
like so my brain is broken yeah all
right bring on the next
flag so a [__] long one oh I got two
that's why what do we got she talks
about marriage on a first
date
ooh okay ooh okay so this is assuming
you're not in the committed relationship
yet you're just on date dat it says she
talks about marriage on the first
date uh okay all right I'm ready
gentlemen all right I think I'm ready as
well all right ready 3 2 1 red none
green really yeah oh okay this is I was
almost I was almost going to put green
uh
because uh yeah like like I think that
I've seen too many people where they hit
these relationship crossroads right A
lot of them come like a lot of them
start dating get along really well date
for years and then everyone hits this
relationship Crossroads do we want to
get married do you ever want to get
married or and do you ever want to have
kids and I've seen so many couples that
have like had just their world destroyed
because they don't want to break up with
this person but they also don't want to
compromise on this very very important
thing which you're allowed to make a
life decision on which is some people
just don't want to get married and
that's respectable I I think you can be
very happy together as a couple and have
it all be perfect and then it'd be a
valid reason to not want to be with
someone any longer because they don't
want to marry like I think to some
people okay I didn't think of it like
that is such a that is like you know I
think it's personal preference like
maybe like I just thought way too fast
right right right I think that's
as well I don't even know you you know
for me it's like I'd rather you tell me
right now what you what you're hoping to
get eventually cuz that's that's what
you saying to me hey we have to get
married it kind of is but it's also like
hey that's how I see this is my
intention is to look someone to marry
which is you know I most people are
looking for in a roundabout way and I
think expressing that that is something
that you are interested in or not
interested in initially is a a
considerate thing to do right and I
think making sure that your intentions
are out right at the beginning of the
relationship I think is respectable you
know because if you ask me 5 years ago
it would have been a red flag cuz I was
young and I was like what the [__] but I
think the older I get the more I'm like
yeah I think it's something that
especially as you get older it's
something that has to be discussed and
why not get it out of the way and too
many people like too many people like
kind of like sweep this on the rug to be
like we'll figure it out eventually and
they put it off and then obviously you
reach same thing with like kids right
kids I think more so with kids
getting married is kind of like get
married but kids is always the normally
a pretty can be a decisive thing and the
thing is I've seen people that have
compromised on this like big life
decision to be like well I don't want to
break up so I'm going to want I'm going
to get married and then it always sounds
like you're in green g I don't know I
don't know if know sounds like you're in
green yeah that sounds very green what
you're saying want you don't want to
commit to the green squad here like
what's wrong D commit way too many times
in the first half of this episode so
he's got to make a compromise okay so
when what's the downside then cuz you
putting on what's the downside uh like
to me like it's neither a red flag or a
green flag it's just like a okay I
understand your intentions uh we can
decide lateer like I can have this in
mind so I can decide it later on but as
long as the intentions are out that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean [__] to
me you know it means I know that if I
like if I want to commit to this
relationship I know that that is the end
goal you know cuz I said red because
it's just a bit too much pressure on a
first
date get to know me on a first date bro
like you know I I get it you know like
cuz I totally get what you mean with
like you know just get all of like that
kind of out of way in the beginning but
a ton of context that could be missing
here like is this a first blind date is
this a date where you've but you've
already spoken for months and I was
thinking of like a blind day that's fair
yeah if it's a blind day I still think
it's valid and yeah but like for me it's
like okay you know what I I just want to
get to like you as a person before I
even want to know about what you want
for me I something like that just puts
pressure on me I like well I guess if if
it puts pressure on you why would you be
feeling pressure about it cuz you feel
like they're trying to marry you or like
well yeah because the way that they say
it could be putting it in that way of
being like I'm so desperate and like you
know I need someone to you know do XYZ
and all that kind of stuff and I am
afraid that I won't be able to commit to
that you know and like for me on a first
date I want to just get to know you as a
person that's fair I don't care about
like you know where you want to be in 10
years or anything like that I just want
to know you right now like what your
pres dat is maybe third or fourth date
sure then we can start then more cuz
you're now you're like it's kind of
working and now you feel like you got to
say yes to the marriage cuz she wants to
get married I don't know but for me it's
just like a bit icky when it happens on
the first dat but that's just me okay
that's just me say it on the first day
thankfully she didn't say it on the
first day all right let's
see and oh Jesus okay all right uh okay
takes more than 30 minutes to get
dressed 30 minutes is such an arbitrary
number you know that's uh can I can can
I say that's that's quick no s he takes
longer than 30 minutes that's so long
bro 30 minutes is quick are we including
Shower time does shower time count no
just getting ready okay okay good good I
was going to say shower time was like
yeah like they're sitting on the couch
and you go honey we're going to go I'm
I'm not crazy 30 minutes is quick right
I think if you're it depends wait wait
okay wait okay hold up hold up what's
the okay we need way more context
situation okay when when are we waking
up or are we are we going out for dinner
like I thought we meant going out for
dinner you know okay so presumably
you're already like showered and
everything you're just putting on
I make and dress I guess yeah just like
dress Jewelry accessories all that kind
of stuff shoes I don't know I I'll be
real with you I I'm playing video games
so
I I just say when we like I'll just tell
you whenever you're ready I'm like this
is when we're going to leave just get
ready for that I don't care if it takes
you 15 hours just be ready to go at this
time how early are you letting them know
Well you mean I just I'm trying to be
punctual what what if if it's like what
if it's just like a super like last
minute decision you know you're both
just like hanging out at home you want
to do something and you just happen to
have the idea of hey you know what so
it's nothing crazy right it's not like
no just like being like hey hey honey
let's go out for dinner get ready and
they take more than 30 minutes is that a
red flag or a green
flag if it was longer than an hour it'd
be red because it's 30 I'll say non I'm
going to say non like I said 30 is very
quick
how long does cityne on average take
huh um so like very much depends if it's
like a fancy night then she needs she
needs an hour like just like I think
anything over an hour that's still
that's still quick for a fancy night
that's quick my Lord that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm saying if this is
like a good
number we've been in long enough
relationships enough to know a fancy
night hour it's like wa are you
compromising something like what are you
not putting in the effort any of your
previous relationship they like ever
reach this point yeah cuz this like
obviously like you know I've been in
multiple relationships and in my in my
frame of reference 30 minutes has been a
very very quick turnaround yeah I'll be
real I I will if I leave with the person
I would be like hey I'm leav we're
leaving at this time just be ready and I
don't really keep track of how long it
takes I just know if it runs over I'm
like oh I guess like I see if we're like
40 minutes late to a thing I'm like come
on yeah oh yeah it's not like it's your
first time doing this it's it's it's
it's okay if they're late it's something
different but like I know I know the
lead time my partner needs in order to
like do like do something I knows
exactly when to start the
split I value being punctual a lot so
I'm like let's be punctual yeah yeah
it's it's it's like if they're late okay
that's something that is a red flag you
know but I like in terms of how I don't
really care how how long it takes you to
get ready as long as you know how long
it takes you to get ready you know and
some people they take over an hour and
uh that's just how long they take you
know I don't really care that much I'll
be real I'm going to be real I'm like
honey yeah I'mma watch some anime while
you spend like I'll do something I'm not
there with as long as we're there on
time and you look amazing that's all I
care about next one all right all right
go on next one then oh is it
me I I know some people though who were
just like super [__] like you know
anal about that stuff but it's
whatever I saw that one what is it they
are a fan of your
content this is presuming presuming
before this is for us we need them
before before you get in a relationship
yeah I would imagine so yeah cuz
obviously like after you I'm sure I I
would hope my partner is a fan of my
[__] first date first date kind of thing
you find out first first date first dat
they're a fan of your content [__]
[__] are we all going to have the same
answer for this yeah yeah I think so I
think so ready 3 2
1ed I'm writing it right now yeah I got
red too it's red were you going to put
beige at the beginning no no no I just I
was [__] right I'm an idiot um I
think that uh I you know it's not always
fun fact uh Mark Rober his wife is a fan
was a fan oh really uh yeah I think
there's a there's tons of examples where
it's gone well and it's fine and there
are tons of examples where it's gone
horribly wrong yeah I think it's just a
it's it gives people a normally there's
normally a bad connotation around it
specifically with just YouTubers in
general because like rock stars or
whatever they don't they [__] it was
never a bad thing I'm I'm saying this
more like a personal level my gut
reaction to like if I'm on like a first
dat they're like oh by the way I like I
really like your stuff I'm like I'm not
a of that that means you know more about
me than I do about you and that makes me
uncomforable I know D is some kind of
like weird parasocial look about you
where they know they think they know a
lot about you through the videos which
in a lot of cases there's a lot that
doesn't get shown on camera well okay
this is like better or worse this is
such an like my person feeling no but
the Nuance to this question is so
numerous like but that's every question
yeah and like being a I could have
watched five of gun's videos and I could
be like yeah I'm a fan of G's videos but
I don't know anything about G I just
know that he's made some videos that I
enjoyed there's so many different layers
of this question I think that because
you know you hear about this all the
time I think YouTubers who date fans
it's generally not a good thing but I
think it's fine it's just if they do
some [__] up [__] yeah it can it can
work as with anything if you treat it
like an adult and you're not like taking
advantage of like this Dynamic that you
have but for me it just like it would
make me uncomfortable because I want to
come into a relationship in like equal
there needs to be that Joy of finding
stuff out about each other you know
you're like what the [__] why you the
rues cube that's crazy really like
probably like one in a million scenario
but hypothetically speaking Yeah if
there was a girl who was a fan of you
but they don't use social media what as
in like they watch YouTube but they
don't do twitch uh Twitter Instagram
Facebook any of that kind of stuff would
that change no it' be a little bit
better I'd feel a bit better about it
but I still would feel a bit like how
much have you seen yeah you see that one
where I look like [__] all the time
which is all of my videos yeah like
that's just like a fifth date kind of
thing yeah like I think most YouTubers
can agree this is kind of a red flag for
on different levels um well yeah I mean
a lot of our stuff is so personal and
our content often we share so much of
ourselves so I think that they yeah like
you said they would know so much about
you yeah already yeah um so I think be
weirdly parasocial um but I mean your
haveu not so much though it's not so
much if they just watched your main
Channel they wouldn't know sure they
wouldn't know much about you yeah I mean
I now that I think like there's a whole
different like Dynamic since ever since
I saw trash taste yeah exactly right
like this like if I if I just made music
on YouTube and never showed my face I
think I'd be like whatever that be
different cuz then like if I VI with
them when it was really chill they
wouldn't know anything about me oh they
like my music that's cool yeah and then
okay okay
they are a fan of trash taste instant
red flag get them out of here why they
know too much this is why you have to go
with our gut don't [__] reason logic
it we can Logic the [__] out of all of
these oh my gut is red and I'm sticking
all right cool turn sweet [__]
[__]
box oh
god
um wow of course I got this one where's
the same outfit a
[Music]
lot yes SE over drip company what do you
think Joey what do you think okay I have
I have My reasonings for
this H all
right wears the same outfit a lot yeah
we don't know anyone who does that no no
one no one I know all right 3 two 1
beige green green why green bro I mean
if you got a great outfit and you're
confident in it [__] rocket what if
it's not a great outfit yeah I mean I'll
just tell them okay but what if it's
like they think it's [__] awesome but
you are just like that a it Chief and
they don't change their mind about it
that's a that's a great concern um yeah
I would hope that I have fallen in love
with every aspect of them including
their outfit choices and then then this
is a win because I like it a lot and
they're wearing it all the time okay
here's here's the thing here's the thing
you you go on three dates
they the same and they wear the same
outfit on three okay like two that would
be
me I you know you at least up being like
you know I wore the twitch shirt yes
purple shirt but next one I'm going to
wear the trash t shirt it's a bang Ral
it's a banger outfit okay what if it's
not a banger outfit odds are it is if
they're wearing it back to back yeah
yeah so so like you'd be surprised man
really I've never heard of such a
thing specifically you only wear the
outfit if it's be surprised I mean I
probably mention it I'll probably uh you
know give a bit of banter about it but
this is way more common for guys than
than uh women in general though yeah
yeah I think guys tend to wear the same
outfits a lot more yeah no definitely
it's but like I I feel like even on
dates you know I mean on dates you're
just like very obviously very conscious
about yeah if you found something that's
comfortable for you though and you you
really feel great in it and uh why not
like do it rock it hey what am I going
to think about yeah I I put beige
because that was me before I met Ary I
used to just wear the same clothes all
the [__] time because I didn't care
about what I wore classic Disney adult
classic no just classic Australian
wearing the same
[__] like then you know cuz like Aki was
super into fashion I got into it because
of her so like I'm thinking about that
now in the opposite side of things being
like well if I like clothes which I do
now and if my partner say for example
wore the same [__] all the time that
would get me excited to be like let's
try on some new [__] let's see what you
like you know and that would give me an
excuse to bond with them as it did for
us so yeah that's why you just took my
like [__] anime and movie answer
Joey you're like this is it this is my
bonding chance it's like a red flag for
that and nowly B suddenly with clothes
you're like o it's a little you can
avoid anime you can't avoid clothes you
know I'm trying my best speak for
yourself Jerry I know you've been trying
your best yeah all right let's see wait
wait that's it's you oh I was going to
tell you he's too deep in the draw
that's whatever all right here we
go they text you every
day oh that's a good one they text you
every is this like what period of the
are we like first date uh territory just
all from first date to like does it make
a difference current I think it does you
think 100% I'm thinking about it
actually doesn't text you every day do
text you every day text you every day
every day it texts you every day for me
it depends
H okay I'm going to I'm going my
reasoning all right yeah I'm going to go
with my go all right all right 3 two one
I said none I said green I should red oh
okay I said none because it really
depends on the frequency like when we
say every day like how often every day
are we talking like every couple of
hours like every five minutes it's very
different right if it's only like a
couple of times a day then I think
that's fine I think there's nothing
wrong I need time to
marinate I got to listen if you if you
that's an out of context clip I need
time to like really know how that I'm
feeling it and the only way I know that
is if I I have a moment where I don't
talk to you and I still think about you
you know what I mean that really lets me
know that I I really it's something
special see this might be different cuz
I was in a long-term relationship where
texting was the only real way to stay in
contact but to me I feel like sometimes
I was guilty of this in school where I
would build I would want to talk to the
person every day not because I wanted to
but out of habit and that I I it was a
thing that we both did and we almost I
almost felt like hostage by it but I
felt that if they didn't text me I would
get like anxious and I and I thought
like that was a bad trait that I
developed uhuh but how often would you
text um it'd be a fair amount yeah be
like a few times a day right and I
didn't like that that I felt reliant on
that right and then when you feel like
you needed to because yeah and then I I
realized I was so much happier when I
felt that like there was no [__]
small talk and when we'd hang out it'd
be really good and we occasionally text
in between but there was no expectation
that it had to be there every day and I
like that a lot and that's to me when I
really know that it's something really
like uh something really worth pursuing
it's like it's like those friends that
you have where you could not talk to
each other for like months on end but
when you meet them again I
I'm that person me too me too I'm like
that too I don't want to text I'm like
hey if you want a call let's have a call
but I don't really want to text much but
now I'll be like you know if I'm if I'm
with someone for a very long time yeah
just to text me and like yeah how's your
day going it's going good all right well
I I'll see you on the weekend or
something that's where I'm kind of
that's where I get to so I do like the
daily text after a while but in the
initial getting together period of that
first few months I don't want to text
every day I I I need to know that we can
can operate outside of each other yeah
it's very important to me right for me
uh I just like get in my own head a lot
uh I don't know if like weak shed that
weakness gone I I don't know if any I
don't know if any guy gets this uh but
it's just like sometimes you overthink
whether like the frequency of the text
and I've kind of realized that I would
rather just [__] know that someone H
like I'm in someone's mind especially
for like thinking no matter what in no
matter what period of the relationship
is I would love to know that I'm in
someone's thoughts thoughts and prayers
uh I'm in someone's thoughts um kind of
like you know on on on like a day-to-day
basis because if I like someone they're
going to be in my thoughts you know and
sometimes I'm I'm that kind of guy who
you guys know I'm [__] horrible at
this [__] so I need someone to just
message me so that I know both being
held hostage by your
anxieties you're both being held hostage
by the equal anxiety you share of
wanting to be wanted by each other yeah
so I need someone to balance me out I
need I I need someone to balance me out
the true Chad moment is when you realize
that you both are happy together and you
don't need to know you don't need to
have each other's attention constantly
yeah no no I totally agree you can be
dependent and independent at the same
time being independent is such an
important thing and that I I learn to
you know sometimes also like you know RV
trip I'm live constantly and then I'm I
then have to when the cameras go off I
got to got to eat sleep and then prepare
the stuff for the next day that be like
a 5day thing where I just can't I I just
don't have the capacity to have a
conversation um and so it's it's just
like I need to know that you're not
going to freak out if I if I'm just kind
of like not really there for 5 days
right yeah yeah no I I no I totally get
that as well um I kind of like I kind of
just think that I think the especially
in like the initial periods right
there's so much of this [__] dance
about should I text should I not text uh
BL blah blah BL am I talking too much am
I talking too little and I think if they
want to talk they're going to [__]
talk and if I don't want to talk like if
I don't want to talk back because I'm
just not vibing or if it's too much then
that's just going to be an indicator for
me sure you know so for me I would
rather someone text me every day when
whenever they actually mean it when they
actually mean it absolutely uh so that I
like I kind of know their intentions and
I know like what they want and I know if
I want to pursue something as well or if
I want to text back cuz most of the time
if they text every day uh I'm going to
be like if I really like them I'm going
to takes back and it's it's going to be
you know it's going to have I think the
key thing here is that I I felt that it
wasn't the question wasn't phrased as
like it's nice to talk every day it's
more like they have to talk every day
right yeah which I think is a big
difference obviously it's nice to talk
every day but I never ever want to have
that feeling that like I need to talk to
them every day so I feel like that that
can breed some toxic uh toxic uh kind of
traits in the relationship right yeah
that they kind of need to be around each
other constantly oh yeah yeah I I
totally I think just just that some
sometimes on busy days just a single
text is enough just to know just know
sometimes you know like I I'm talking
like personally sometimes I have like
similar days where I have no [__]
time at all where I'm working all day
but just knowing it's like Hey Sydney
how's your day been and she's been like
it's good I'm making dinner I'm like
you know that's all you need that's
that's all I need you know that's that's
that's what I want so yeah green flag
for me yeah very very different
depending on personality types I feel
yes all right you oh it's me you it oh
okay all right what's the next one
got oh God you're
laughing
what they ask to um they ask for your
phone
passcode uh is this normal uh I guess um
maybe not normal but it happens yeah it
it does happen I mean do we even have to
do the reveal I think we already know
right it's red it's [__] red privacy
is very important in uh you need to have
some semblance of it absolutely um you
can have nothing to hide yeah and I
think it's valid to to not not want to
give that out I think people who ask of
their partners for their phone uh you
know passwords because they're afraid
that like their partner is hiding
something is just projecting themselves
onto their partner like like people who
do that clearly have been in a past
where like they've had to hide something
themselves and so you know because they
have stuff to hide they think well I
have stuff to hide so maybe my partner
also has stuff to hide too maybe I
should get his phone code so like that's
just a media red flag it's it's like to
me um I've actually experienced this
with like previous relationships
actually um it's it's almost like the
catch22 you know it's like what came
first the chicken or the egg except it's
like oh you trust them so you should
have no problem giving them your phone
passcode but you if you have nothing to
hide you can give it but like it like to
me in my experience it builds a very
something toxic kind of trust system it
is it is the wrong kind of mentality
where you know if you trust your partner
you should have no problem giving them
your passcode but if they trust you they
wouldn't ask for your part code a
passcode it's it's it's you you've got
nothing to hide is the the the scummiest
defense to to overreach in the history
of overreaching because you know the of
course you got nothing to hide but also
privacy is allowed yeah you know like
you are allowed to have things private
and that is a right that you get to have
as a human being I you looking I don't
want you snooping through my [__]
files without my permission in any
situation do I have to explain every
meme on my phone
no like there's a I think if you ask do
I have to explain my Google ass to you
this would be a uh a relationship Ender
for me I think if someone asked me of
this I think this this would and if they
were pushing it after I said no I think
i' that would yeah that' be a
relationship yeah I I think so too I
think people who do this uh don't don't
do it yeah goes well yeah I think you
know there's a fallacy in like every
relationship where you have to share
every single part of yourselves with
your partner and I think a good an
important thing about relationships is
that you're just acknowledging that
you're individual people um with your
own like wants and privacy and whatever
and you are comfortable with that I feel
like a lot of couples get insecure if
they don't if they if they don't have
like prove to themselves they're like oh
I know everything about my partner we we
are like one soul and I'm like H to me
that's not like that's not what a
balanced relationship is in my op you
know no I agree I agree with that all
right that was an easy uh clean red flag
sweep Clean Sweep baby I hope everyone
at home also said red all right this is
the last one last one there is only one
more here we go and I was feeling like
we had a natural conclusion as well
yeah
she
uh what the [__] have they written this
sheia low but I think it's a 10 oh wait
oh she a 10 oh my God she a low she a
low I was like I was like what it was
formatted really weird but put okay yeah
it really she 10 sorry I I was trying to
read this and I was like is it I crazy
it looks format really bizarre she's a
10 but put put milk before cereal wait
what uh she puts milk before her cereal
she's a 10 but she puts milk before her
cereal and you said Point Crow something
she a pointcrow tweet oh is it okay so
this is a tweet from uh Point Crow
fellow content creator yeah who said
she's a 10 but she pours milk before her
cereal
okay how do I answer
this all
right okay all right ready three two 1
green clearly a red flag guys green I
don't give a [__] about how your to the
streets Joey be some things you will not
be in my hous are important before
cereal couldn't give two fat rats assers
about how you pour your cereal you're a
10 Joey we have rules for a reason
civilization was built on reason and
structure and if people don't follow
that structure civilization crashes a
cow Who provided that milk give a [__]
about how
it's doesn't like to follow a rigid set
of rules until today well guess I'm a
[__] Rebel then to the streets I
don't a [__] how you pour your cereal no
I don't really
care I do think it's [__] up but I
wouldn't end a relationship it's a bit
beige it's like a beige green why would
you insist on having a worse experience
I'd uh call them out for it I just don't
really care I'm like if that's how you
like it that's fine just don't make me
do the same [__] it's like putting the
milk in the tea before you've put the
tea in it's like why are you doing this
you're doing this so much hard of
yourself I just think to myself oh
you're [__] lost I'm still eating
cereal the delicious deal no I don't
really give a [__] but there you go that
was the red flag green flags um that was
fun that was a lot of fun yeah hopefully
you guys enjoyed that let us know your
uh red flags and green flags down in the
comments below we'd love to check them
out and uh hopefully you I wonder how
many people have started to see us
differently after
this now you know what we're really like
oh my friends hate Disney adults [__]
them agree you know what if you haven't
seen any Classic Movies I could show you
the way I could show you the way you're
a [__] ple what some godfa God damn
it thank you so much for watching this
episode of trash T Take it Away Joe yo
check out these patrons though I hope
you guys don't pour milk before your
cereal cuz that is actually psychotic
thisy do yeah don't unless you're a 10
then I going give a [__] but uh Hey if
you like to support the show uh then
make sure to go to our patreon
patreon.com traste also follow us on
Twitter send us your memes on the subor
and if you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and we will see you guys next
week
[Music]
byebye